My office is in an old building.
It's near the market.
There are three rooms on our floor.
In the first room, there are many workstations.
In the second room, there is a big meeting space.
There are fifty chairs and a small stage inside the room.
My favorite room is the dining hall.
We take our break there.
My office is in a busy street.
It can be noisy sometimes, but my co-workers and I love the place.
My favorite room in the office is the open working space.
There are long tables and big computers in the room.
There is a couch where we can sit when we want to take a break.
I also like the plants around the working space.
They are good to see.